in a happy twist kichi returns home to a
telegram revealing that noro is actually
still alive the chaos in the Ginza
attack left many victims injured and
lost with no way to identify them it
seems that this fate also befell noro
who sustained wounds from Godzilla's
heat ray blast but survived after being
taken to a hospital kuichi rushes to her
bedside with Akiko in his arms and the
family is reunited as a happy reunion
Fades out the camera shifts suspiciously
to noro's neck where the faintest sign
of something dark can be seen undulating
beneath the skin this could simply be
some kind of ordinary radiation
poisoning but with Godzilla still being
an unknown quantity in this Incarnation
it could also be a sign of something
more Sinister perhaps noro is exposed to
some kind of Godzilla DNA or G cells as
they've often been called in previous
movies such an infection might have even
helped her survive her injuries for now
though there's too little evidence to
say for certain what's happening to her